in a violation of free speech rights
boycotting Israel could become illegal
in the u.s. proposed legislation in
Congress would make it a crime for
Americans to boycott Israel even though
that is their constitutionally protected
right for years Congress has tried to
pass laws that would criminalize a
boycott of Israel a top priority for the
pro-israel lobby and major donors to
both Democrats and Republicans these
laws would make it illegal for Americans
to refuse on political grounds to do
business with Israel they portray the
boycott divestment sanctions movement as
a form of anti-semitism well I'm not
aware of instances in history where
there has been an effort through federal
legislation to attempt to criminalize
political boycotts which are of course
constitutionally protected activity BDS
is a movement calling on supporters to
withhold business and cultural
interactions with Israel as a
non-violent form of pressure to demand
Palestinian rights in early 2019 the
previously introduced combatting BDS act
to advance in Congress this bill would
have given state and local governments
the power to boycott any businesses that
boycott Israel it's also being pushed
forward by the pro-israel lobby and
would work to legally strengthen already
existing anti BDS laws at the state
level this comes after Congress failed
to pass the Israel anti-boycott act as
part of a spending bill before the end
of its term in 2018 there's some
powerful forces who just want to throw
it into the bill and that force it
through without fuller reflection from
the body-fat shakir of the American
Civil Liberties Union says the proposed
legislation violates Americans
constitutionally protected freedom of
speech he believes many members of
Congress are unaware of the
constitutional implications of this
legislation
the Israel anti-boycott act proposes
prohibiting boycotts against allies of
the United States specifically calling
out boycotts against Israel for the ACLU
that's a huge issue it's trying to chill
and stifle speech merely because
somebody has a viewpoint that they don't
like and once you go down that road of
course anybody is susceptible to being
targeted for politically unpopular
speech and Youssef manera of the US
campaign for Palestinian rights says
these laws are specifically directed at
groups like his the basic point of this
act and the supporters of the
legislation all on record saying this is
to combat the Palestinian rights
movement here in the United States which
has adopted of course boycott divestment
and sanctions tactics
edie s has already scored some notable
successes celebrities like Danny Glover
and Naomi Klein have publicly called for
boycott of Israel I support BDS and I've
supported BDS since 2009 the question is
what do you do when a when a people
under illegal occupation come together
and chart out a way for the rest of the
world to express their solidarity and
support them even church groups like
Presbyterian Church USA the United
Church of Christ and others have
announced divestment from Israel
Israel's supporters are seeking to shut
down the movement as support grows for
citizen action like BDS today 26 states
have passed anti BDS laws with 13
additional states considering similar
measures as well but in two separate
court cases federal judges in Kansas and
Arizona ruled that state laws punishing
individuals or companies for partaking
in BDS were unconstitutional and
violated free speech rights meanwhile
the anti Semitism awareness act would
force the US Department of Education to
treat criticism of Israel as
anti-semitic harassment in other words a
violation of the Civil Rights Act the
problem of legislating on it is you're
casting too wide a net and you're
suggesting activity is anti-semitic that
really isn't anti-semitism it's merely a
difference of a point of view on a
policy area this would effectively
stifle the speech of Palestinian rights
advocacy groups like Meniere's
organization and ironically would use
anti-semitism as grounds to silence even
Jewish critics of Israel like Jewish
Voice for Peace and if not now here's
Jewish academic Judith Butler of Jewish
Voice for Peace on BDS support for
boycott divestment and sanctions is just
that it is a support for a social
justice movement and that it does not
imply anti-semitism but I think because
you know the the State of Israel has
also gone to great lengths to conflate
Judaism and Zionism there
understanding in our discourse that
somehow these things are more tied than
they are in reality the First Amendment
prevents Congress from making laws that
limit free speech and the ACLU has
publicly criticized these pieces of
legislation for undermining
constitutional values the legal fight is
of course over whether you can impose a
criminal fine or a civil fine merely
because somebody has a viewpoint that
you don't like and the answer on that is
obviously you cannot so what happens if
these pieces of legislation are passed
and become law let's start with the
Israel anti-boycott Act this law is
actually an amendment of the 1979 export
administration Act which prohibited u.s.
citizens and companies from boycotting
friendly nations US citizens would also
be unable to request any information
about companies that conduct business
relations with Israel and wouldn't even
be allowed to notify the UN if it's
unknowingly doing business with Israel
so the legal consequences are broad it
could be really anything the things that
I fear here is that a federal government
passes anti Israel boycott act and what
may happen is that federal prosecutors
throughout America now have new tools at
their disposal to target protesters on
this issue under this proposed law both
individuals and companies could face
financial penalties for supporting EU or
UN backed boycotts of Israel Israeli
companies and specifically those in the
occupied West Bank the point here is to
intimidate rights activists for engaging
in constitutionally protected activity
by threatening them with the specter of
criminalization and steep fines
violations of the law could see US
citizens paying up to two hundred and
fifty thousand dollars in civil
penalties willful violations of the law
could see citizens fined up to 1 million
dollars and then there's the
anti-semitism awareness Act which the
ACLU and other activist organizations
have issued statements opposing this is
legislation that would actually call on
the Department of
patient to adopt a particular definition
of anti-semitism or a particular
understanding of anti-semitism which it
should take into consideration as it
looks at civil rights discrimination
complaints this bill would work to
silence critics and criticism of Israel
in schools colleges and universities and
institutions of learning would also work
to ensure that their campuses are spaces
where criticism of Israel cannot occur
violating their free speech rights to
avoid investigations by the Department
of Education so a student protester
who's on a listserv having a debate
about Palestinian issues could easily be
castigated for having engaged in
anti-semitism and then fear the wrath of
a federal agency this could result in
numerous lawsuits and court cases in
which activists and educational
institutions sue the government for
violations of their free speech and
civil rights and so what gets Unleashed
here is potentially prosecutors who use
this power in very unfortunate ways but
the other ramification as you well know
is that culturally it suggests something
to all Americans about what will not be
tolerated and that is of course this
chilling of speech that we worry greatly
about but despite the possibility of
these pieces of legislation becoming law
to US Congress women have stated their
support for BDS Ilhan Omar of Minnesota
and Rasheeda to leave of Michigan have
come out in support of BDS Talib is
saying she'll lead a congressional
delegation to the occupied West Bank in
2019 and that would be a first Bonet or
says this is a sign of changing times
when you look at public opinions seeing
a shift on this issue as well and
primarily the Republican base of white
evangelicals being hyper supportive of
Israel in the base of the Democratic
Party in particular Millennials and
people of color being much much more
critical of Israeli policy and
supportive of the rights of Palestinians
but manner is still concerned about the
legislation potentially being passed and
what that will mean for free speech and
organizing or
Palestine for vulnerable communities
including people who are working on
Palestinian rights work they have even
more reason to be concerned about the
way in which this would be enforced very
much for the purpose of intimidating
them and marginalizing them hey guys
hope you enjoyed the video make sure you
hit that subscribe button when you get a
chance were you aware of all the
different laws and bills that are
fighting media let us know in the
comments